[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from CD Projekt RED
executive producer John mom ice and
Conrad Thomas kovitch hello Conrad and I
are totally thrilled to be able to
premiere some new gameplay of The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt let's get right into
it
so witches are trained from birth to
find and kill monsters for reward
here were about ten hours into the game
on a Griffon hunt the Griffon is nearby
so we've trapped for a possible
encounter here coming to a chest it's
gridlines prey items needed for combat
in this instance a set of buffing
potions and a small crossbow as mutants
witcher's possess heightened senses that
can be used on command to among other
things track prey we can better perceive
visual and sound clues in this state
and hasn't cover my scent yet it's an
attack but the bolts we fired will leave
a trail of blood behind to help us track
it this sequence is set in a vast
wilderness area known as no-man's land
we can reverse any viewable location in
the world all the way to the mountain
peaks in the distance and beyond so
we're losing him now so we need to pick
up his tracks again
[Music]
[Music]
you can come out damn it he only came
for a broom to break a fever what are
you doing here
dragging a griffon trail took me through
here since I had a stroke of luck then
thank you look like deserters could be
more bands in the area I'll come back
once I'm done with the Griffon just in
case fine
happy hunting
Mozza running quests can often intersect
in the open world with points of
interest so by dispatching those bandits
we can now return to the herbalist later
in the game now we'll continue on the
hunt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this was just a very small part of the
epic RPG that of The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
thanks for watching thanks to the Ziya
beast a team back in Warsaw for their
tremendous effort
[Music]